and here he comes it's the two-time TFA
TK champion rack Inc we get a word you
can get a whole sentence little Gerry
it's Gianni what took so long to get the
belt in the first place listen here baby
Jarvis everybody knows that bran is
shop-vac and Bryan Callas
got a little bit of slow in her mojo but
your cane her if a Kenya and you could
hear the belts are coming and these are
rolling around the bin and I ain't took
an L since I don't know when are you
worried about protecting your dynasty
ain't worried about nothing and you
could tell him this and you could tell
him that little Bobby and you could tell
him that and you could tell him this
they said he can't win one and it was
and the rat came through
you keep saying de who's they can
explain it I'm talking to the hate
layers and then they say errs Kristen
Lea sent him in naughty emails at night
after his shattered rap career and
Andrew Sam Timmy that alcoholic burn
victim they're all after my cheddar they
want to beso the case Oh baby so I'm
telling all of you that anti-american
tacky methyl port and that hungry
skeleton Hani chintz cliff and that
little Vietnamese side rib mr. Barbie
Lee you only get in bed with the lad
brother
you want a wrong with the chrome you
know where to find me
because I'm a high light with the pie
right I'm the varmint with the sermon
and don't you forget it because the road
to the strap goes through the wrath
did you enjoy that clip well you really
would have enjoyed it if he was watching
on a TCL TV TCL is America's fastest
growing TV brand it's so fast it's the
Carl Lewis of television brands it's
that Florence Griffith visual jointer
it's celebrating its fifth anniversary
from launching in the US markets I have
one of these at home and these suckers
are just I mean it's like having a Mona
Lisa on your wall that plays everything
you want follow TCL at TCL underscore
USA on Twitter and Instagram for more
details for more information about TCL
visit TCL usa.com
that's TCL usa.com